a crew member for the show law and order
was shot and killed in brooklyn this
morning while reserving a parking spot
for the production the investigation is
ongoing no arrests have been made here
with reaction for former florida
attorney general pam bondi along with
fox news legal analyst greg jarrett pam
i don't even know why it was a question
we had the video we had the audio i
don't want any trouble he was attacked
he was pushed down you know against the
wall and fell down he got up to defend
himself
and you know at that point it's called
self-defense isn't it
yeah sean and legally he was the victim
from day one he was always a victim not
only that they held him initially on
half a million dollar bond he should
have never been held in jail what if
something had happened to that victim
while he was held in jail he finally got
released from jail by a judge and now
the charges are dropped legally he
should have never been charged the
criminal is dead and his girlfriend
should be charged for stabbing the
victim in the case it's unbelievable and
it's just it's a city in chaos there
that's what's happening and when you
have a d.a who doesn't support victims
of crimes um it's just it's going to get
worse and worse until it gets better
until we elect these people out of
office
what is your take on gofundme policies
here uh he was only charged with the
crime he was not found guilty of a crime
greg jarrett and yet in this case of
this guy we have the evidence he fired
these
these bullets into this woman's house
with young kids
yeah well it's completely backwards and
the bodega worker you know this is the
only case i've seen recently where
an idiot prosecutor actually files
charges before conducting an
investigation and that should have been
an easy one look at the tape
but the problem is that major cities
like new york are run by liberal
democrats and progressive da's that have
instituted the social justice policies
that have nothing to do with justice
they only incentivize crime and
criminals are treated as pam said like
victims and innocent victims like the
bodega worker are criminals the leftists
who control these municipalities they
don't believe in law and order sean they
embrace lawlessness and disorder because
that's woke and god forbid you ever
offend the progressives and new york is
such a prime example liberal lawmakers
ended the bail for most offenses they
created a revolving door of criminality
and the repeat perpetrators they adore
it they love it when they're arrested
they're back out on the streets before
the paperwork is completed they're
already committing even more crimes the
blm and defund police movements
shattered effective policing the ranks
of officers shrank those who remain and
commend them for doing so they fear
retribution for simply doing their jobs
they're handcuffed by senseless policies
and nutballing competent politicians who
resist common sense
will this chase people out of these
cities there was a study that showed 44
percent of san francisco residents want
out in the next two years pam
absolutely san francisco portland new
york sadly um so many other places and
sean when you have starbucks spain that
it's not safe to have their stores open
in many of these cities that's a huge
problem it's not a recipe for crime
reduction when you have da's supporting
criminals over victims when you have
politicians not backing up our great men
and women in blue when criminals are
more emboldened than police officers
it's a problem and it's got to change
that's why people have to look at their
elections for da's and judges in these
cities
i think that's well said anyway
pam thank you greg jarrett thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else